good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and
happy hump day theo is here
do not forget to hump someone you love
it is the most important day of the week
signifying one
that you can help someone you love and
two the latter half of the week is upon
us yeah it's a beautiful thing to behold
such is theo being here back on the show
he missed two days of work it was
really hard i feel like the vibes were
just not what they could be with
out theo in the room he's so happy he's
back he's ready for
he's ready to get his hump on oh my god
he's looking so delicious i want to eat
you
do you want to put my nose up
oh god he's turned um so yes happy
wednesday
there is so much going on in the world
we of course are here to break it down
for you
former bachelor colton underwood came
out as gay this morning on good morning
america we have lots of thoughts
it's wednesday so of course it's hump
day we also have deer toasters our
advice segment and a real
high point for everyone in my opinion
yes and
we had one of our merch drops this
morning the 100 collection is now
officially available
at shopmorningtoast.com we've got mugs
we've got
crewnecks we've got sweatpants we've got
stickers we've got phone cases we've got
hats
hat we've got hat and we've got mr hat
and you know they are flying like
hotcakes so make sure you head over to
shopmorningtoast.com
i am here wearing the pink crew neck
that says honorable in size extra large
i'm wearing size medium i've been
wearing medium all week
this material i've been getting a lot of
questions about the material i would
compare it to beautiful stunning and
smart because
like super light also back in the day
the sorority crewnecks if you grabbed
one of those teal ones
the teal 100 is very similar to that so
it's much lighter than how you turn
yeah the how you turn and the red head
sweatshirts were more winter based
sweaters and thick but these are more
lightweight so like we're wearing them
on a beautiful spring day and i honestly
feel like
perfectly suited for the weather me too
i'm wearing shorts and this and i walked
here
and it was absolutely delightful like
the breeze between my thighs
also today's your first day of showing
your legs yeah i guess like
you know i tried to deny it for as long
as i could like spring is
officially here therefore like summer is
around the corner um
not really where i wanted to be you know
body wise but you know what hot girl
summer knows no bounds and mine has
officially started
i'm so happy for you i'm so happy to see
your legs right beside
my legs today if i were you i would be
happy that my legs are here too because
mine are so much more pale
and like big than yours and they're just
like distracting because yours are
looking lovely today well my legs had
their introductory day yesterday so they
were feeling like shy yesterday
but now they're like they're comfortable
and so my legs are saying hi to your
legs and make wanting
your legs to feel like welcome and
comfortable you want to touch
um so we have a really busy show and i
don't want to like dilly dally but
i do want to clear up some rumors um
claudia says there's rumors about me
there is there is and i'm not even
joking there's just been like at least
for me and i don't know if people are
reaching out to you
there has been an outpouring from our
toaster community people are like
worried about you they just feel like
you have been talking a lot about your
retreat and like you're kind of going to
this retreat
for a reason okay um like are you
feeling down people are just like
feeling like you're maybe feeling off
i told the community that in my personal
opinion i think you're fine
okay now i realize what you're talking
well so when i saw one post and talks
after dark because like after monday
the poster felt like there was something
off with me i felt sad
definitely monday all day i like woke up
wrong
and i usually like at some point in the
morning it corrects itself
but like all day i was just unwell like
mentally physically i was so
tired and i was just like i can't
with today i went to live meth and i was
just like yeah
you know so monday was a wash for me
okay
that has nothing to do with like the
wellness retreat like i really am going
to the retreat like for my physical
being like 20 20.
like when we went into the pandemic like
i was really in the best shape of my
life yeah
and then the year just completely
deteriorated that and now we're coming
out of it and i'm like expected to be
the same person
that i was but like i'm not so i just
want to get this year
off me physically that is a great
explanation and also
mentally so i i'm just taking matters
into my own hands like i'm i'm sick of
like every monday being like and now
it's going yeah
yeah like i just need a jump start and i
feel like the wellness retreat
will be that i know it's not gonna like
solve all my problems but it will like
right now i don't even know what i'm
doing like eating wise like i'm just
like
snacking all day and i'm also like not
even if i get motivated like i just lose
momentum so quickly because i'm still
not going anywhere so i'm just like why
not have
a cookie in my house that's going to
make me happy as opposed to like
drinking you know what you're saying
it's just like depriving myself for like
this when i get out
now what do you say to the rumors that
you are actually not going to a wellness
retreat but you are going to rehab
is that a rumor because i did a q a
yesterday just like talking [ __ ] you
know and i got like a bunch of questions
like about you how you're doing and then
someone said
is jackie going to rehab and i just
think you should clear up those rumors
and tell your truth finally
okay finally i'm not going to rehab um
but like
no i'm not going to rehab i actually
have never been drinking less in my life
yeah camera light um i don't know what
the person would think i was going to
rehab for like what addiction
maybe investment addiction my addiction
is food and so i'm going on a [ __ ]
street by the way speaking of
investments
everyone who held on to dogecoin today
was a good day yesterday was a good day
yeah do you have any dojo
no i do not i bought 200 of dogecoin and
like i bought it at 0.04
and as of last night it's at point 11.
or actually this morning was at point
12. have you made money
i invested 199 and now i have 500
but i don't have it until i pull it out
and it's like do i pull it out now don't
pull it out you leave it there like
forever
oh for real yeah because that's what you
do with traditional stocks but like but
it's
dogecoin to the moon so like you're not
at the moon yet i know i'm like you're
like so
you're still even in this stratosphere
like you're nowhere at point 11. no i
know i'm so panicked i should keep it
you say
forget about it like i did forget about
it but yesterday and forget it okay okay
it's been like two weeks if anyone has
like a really hot tip like just please
oh actually no that's insider trading
please do not come for me okay yeah yeah
no but if you have um not a tip but like
advice yeah there's plenty of financial
advisors
i need one yeah you do need one so i'm
so glad that you
are thank you everyone for being like so
in tune with how i'm feeling i know and
i also have gotten like so many
people reaching out one to be like where
are you going like i i need a wellness
retreat as well
and two like people who are feeling
similarly it's just been like a rough
one i'm just ready to put it all
behind to start anew you know well if
people are really interested in the
journey you will be vlogging it for our
patreon patreon.com morning toast
and really like the vlog hammer's gonna
be like my only friend because i'm going
almost like any time i have a
thought or like a joke like i'm gonna
talk to the vlogger it'll probably be
really healthy for you to like kind of
have like a video diary outlet
yeah no otherwise like i'm just gonna be
bottled up so solitary so
when i come back to my room i could be
like hey guys like you just did this and
that really sad
you should go live on instagram and
stuff so like you could have people to
talk to i don't like going live on
instagram but i hear what you're saying
okay no or if you just like facetime
everyone like i do from my bed every
single day
um so yeah i'm really really excited i
leave
on sunday and i will keep you all
abreast of my progress and i'm just like
really looking forward to a new
sensation
i'm so happy for you i will be a
programming update for
monday through wednesday of next week
while you are gone ben will be joining
me in studio
that's exciting um yes he has agreed to
all three episodes but i have to record
like super early in the morning so just
kill me um that'll be exciting and then
thursday friday of next week ben and i
have to head to florida for a simple
so there will be no episodes yeah
there's never going to be episodes
anyway which is why it worked out
perfect to take the retreat that week so
just keep in mind we're back in studio
next week
for sure but thursday friday there are
no shows great i'm excited for ben
i'll probably like listen to the podcast
every day like while i'm on my walks and
my
retreating yeah and so make sure it's
good
yeah make sure it's good yeah i'll be
listening
wow i'll hear what you say we listen
every day oh we're not gonna say
anything about you no i don't always
listen when i'm not here
no but you listen you're always here and
you listen every day because you do the
show every day you didn't know
what i was saying but like i'm going to
be like listening every day like because
i'm going to be like just a listener i
heard that yeah i heard it twice
you know i i think that you heard it but
you weren't listening no no i
fully heard like the whole thing not
once but twice and i think maybe now
that would be the third time but i
wasn't sure that you were listening
but i was i always listen to you you're
so smart and beautiful and stunning
the lies should we dive in because like
it's just like how can we talk about
anything other than colton
yes oh but i did finish my book and i
just want to share wouldn't recommend it
to you okay
by the end like i was i was fine with
sort of fine with how it ended but it
was a really frustrating book like a
little creepy and like not in like an
interesting way in like a creepy ass way
and um the main character like was so
infuriating at times so
i think some people would like it i'm
not recommending it to you thank you it
was the hunting wives
thank you for your honesty yeah but um i
rated it a three because
the end it ended pretty well but it was
just frustrating
and that's that on that fabulous oh
and now without further ado do where
are you he's right here because he's
here today on hump day here are the fast
side stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
fabulous and i'm very excited because
it's laundry day for me which means my
sheets are finally being washed
um and it's very appropriate that
today's episode is brought to you by
bowling branch where all my sheets are
from and i absolutely love bowling
branch
it's good to know what goes into your
everyday essentials and every night
essentials like
sheets make a stand by laying down on
quality sheets made by more ethical
textile and manufacturing
so bowling branch not only is the most
fabulous set of sheets they're so
reasonably priced
i've had them since before they were a
sponsor because uh rich parcell put them
on her instagram story and i thought if
they were good enough for raid to parcel
they'd be good enough for me
and then once i learned more about
bowling branch it's like i feel good
sleeping in them and i feel good you
know spending my money on a company
that's better for the planet
21 000 metric tons of carbon emissions
have been saved thanks to bowling branch
they use sustainable raw materials
organic cotton wool
responsible down recycled springs
natural latex latex
they have no harmful pesticides or gmos
and it's better for the people
they have a fair trade certified process
and it is 100 source from family owned
businesses
they have 2.8 million pounds of fair
trade seed cotton purchase and they're
helping over
12 000 farmers stay out of debt so you
can feel good knowing that not only do
the sheets that you have
uh feel like everything of the sort um
but they also are ethically made
sustainably made and that feels good
i i'm very particular with sheets
because i am a nighttime sweater i sweat
in my sleep
and so i like um light uh fabrics
fabrics that are cooling fabrics that
don't make me sweat
and i've been using volume ranch now for
like i revamped my whole bed like a few
months ago and it's been truly life
changing
if you want to feel the difference
quality can make head over to
bowlingbranch.com and you can get 15
off your first set of sheets when you
use the promo code toast at checkout
that's bowlin branch b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch dot com promo code toast check it
out
i really stand by these sheets i've been
using them since before they were a
sponsor
and they're super cute sometimes you
just need
a fresh yes and that's what the pandemic
taught me like my sheets were not
cutting it yeah and your bed needs to be
your happy place and with bowling branch
academy
sign on make your bed your happy place
so i know okay first story the big story
of the day the bachelor's colton
underwood comes out as gay
he says i've ran for myself for a long
time colton underwood is speaking his
truth the former bachelor star 29 came
out as gay during a sit-down interview
with robin roberts
that aired on gma this morning during
the personal conversation titled colton
underwood
in his own words he said he came to
terms with his sexuality earlier this
year after a long period of
self-reflection
he said quote i've ran for myself for a
long time i've hated myself for a long
time
and i'm gay and i came to terms with
that earlier this year and have been
processing it
the next step in all of this was letting
people know i'm still nervous
it's been a journey for sure i'm
emotional but in such a good happy
positive way
i'm the happiest and healthiest i've
ever been in my life and that means the
world to me
so i feel like there's a lot to break
down here yes the first is that
i think that it's unimaginably hard to
grow up
in football very religious
and struggle with these thoughts and i
think it's like huge of him
and i'm so happy really really happy for
him that like he got to this place
um and i don't want to take away from
that because at the end of the day like
this is a celebration
i'm really really happy for him and i i
actually can't even imagine like what
it's like
not only to like struggle with the
secret but also in the environment that
he was in the bachelor which is like
so heteronormative and like football
which is like
and he said in his interview like you're
surrounded by people who are just like
that's so gay and like
that is only used for negative things
right so
i i can imagine like how painful
confusing that is and like when he said
because he's so religious he used to
like literally pray at night like please
take the gay away and when he got chosen
as a bachelor like he's never been
happier because he thought that like
god quote-unquote like fixed him and
like took the gay away
but there's a whole other element to
this story which is
really not being spoken about and it's
like i am
happy for colton but also like i'm a
little sad for cassie at the same time
because like
as everyone knows we reported on like a
few months ago like colton was like
stalking and harassing cassie like
putting trackers on her car um
and i think that what i'm struggling
with that i think maybe other people are
struggling with too is like
how to kind of reconcile being like
really happy for colton
but also like having empathy for cassie
right and also reconciling this happy
moment with
you know the last piece of news we heard
about him which was that he was engaging
in stalker behavior
right and like cassie is now like a
victim of his who's like seeing him
being universally celebrated
which like i'm struggling with like he
should be but like i can
i just have like a lot of empathy for
cassie and i feel like she's really not
being spoken about
and especially in the interview like
with robin i feel like they really
glazed over it and there was like one
question about it maybe there was more
and they edited it out
but robin was just like well what would
you say to cassie
he was like i would say i'm sorry but
like did you say you're sorry like have
you spoken to cassie like yeah
where does cassie stand i mean it's only
been a few hours since it came out and
maybe she'll
speak for herself but i feel like i
don't think sheryl we don't really hear
a lot from her i feel like he's
you know he's obviously very public and
he said a lot about a number of things
over the years and she's always been
kind of private for
a person who was on the bachelor yes so
i wrote a whole book and like she's
saying she didn't comment on it even
when like they were
the restraining order stuff was
happening when they were breaking up we
still didn't hear that much from her
yeah so i don't imagine that things
might change now but i agree with you
like you have to
wonder how she's feeling yeah right now
and i i imagine that she's
known from this about colton either he
told her
um because she's really never publicly
disparaged him in any way like even when
he's given her
reason to okay stalking and harassing
her um
so i feel like cassie's actually like
cassie's a really good person
and i would like to hear from her but
you're right like she has maintained
uh actually unusual level of privacy for
someone who won the bachelor and someone
who even like went on the bachelor's
just like unnatural for bachelor
contestants it really is
but at the same time like i just i can't
stress enough like how i think
colton's setting a really good example
for people who you know
are in sports for people who grew up
very religious for people in bachelor
nation like
the impact of this is huge and i don't
want to downplay that
but i also don't want to downplay the
fact that like we can't just like glaze
over
the fact that like cassie is
like a victim of his yes i i agree with
you and i think that we can have both of
those feelings and feel
happy for him and then also want to
still hold him accountable for those
things yeah i'm happy for him but i'm
more so like happy for like the
the um the precedent he sets you know
because it really is like the first
i think the first cast member oh well
demi lead well then the first lead yeah
and it's a really like big deal and
people in the gay community are
celebrating him as they should and i'm
really happy for him
i'm because you could tell happy for him
he was so nervous
in the interview like it's clear that
like he's not even like fully
like i can't believe that like this is
happening yeah and i actually thought it
was really sweet when he said like
the most impactful thing was like when
he told his dad and instead of saying i
love you his dad was like who can i tell
for you like what can i take off
your pants how can i help and i thought
that was really sweet and he was so
visibly nervous i do need to talk to
someone at gma
uh in the audio department about the
misophonia about the microphone like why
was it the most
high-tech microphone i could literally
hear him swallowing i could hear him
breathing
and he was obviously nervous but a lot
of people go on gma and do interviews
where they're nervous and i don't hear
like the inside of their
justices don't hear their thoughts yeah
like it was such a crazy microphone i
was curious about the only one who
picked out
i noticed it and i usually don't pick up
on like audiences things like that like
it
typically doesn't bother me me too i
noticed it too immediately
and i don't know if they were doing it
like for dramatic effect because it was
obviously like a very nerve-wracking
thing to say out loud
yeah but i just had a like i had a
problem with it and it's obviously not
important but i was just curious if
other people picked up on it
yeah no i picked up on it i had a
problem with it
and but i don't think it was on purpose
no i mean i don't know it was so loud
so loud but ultimately i'm really happy
for coles and i feel like we'll we'll
the reactions will start to roll in life
from bachelor nation and and maybe
cassie or people who know him and i
think everyone's
whenever someone chooses to you know be
their authentic self and shed what other
people think they're supposed to be it's
it's a celebration it's a joyous
occasion i agree and i feel like
he was so different in that interview
than like we'd ever seen him before
and i really am happy and honestly like
he is
already like the most eligible bachelor
literally
in the gay community again every single
one of my gay friends texted me and was
like do you know him like how do we get
set up like what is he like and i'm like
oh my god i literally don't know him but
he's super nice
but now we have to we have to set him up
yeah mentally
mentally yeah um so yeah this was just
like a crazy
story yeah but exciting development yes
happy for colton truly yeah are you
ready for our next story
yes because olivia rodrigo has announced
her debut album
sour will be out next month the 11 track
project will feature her hit single
driver's license i want to go through
the
tracks yeah well i think the name sour
is very
appropriate no it's so appropriate and
actually because like
it actually makes me feel like really
good about like
that she's self-awareness yes exactly
with these two songs that have come out
everyone's like get over it like you
lost your boyfriend to another girl like
get over it get over it
it's clear she's not getting over it and
the entire album's about it because the
title is named sour and all the tracks
and here are the tracks
brutal traitor
[Laughter]
driver's license which is actually the
most benign type of them all even though
the song is like
savage one step forward three steps back
deja vu good for you enough for you
happier jealousy jealousy favorite crime
hope you're okay yeah i like how she
ended it being like i'm so mad and then
it's like hope you're okay i think
that's like a natural course of emotions
for like a young emotional person i
think that's an emotional journey of an
out that an album can take you on yeah
so if you were like one of those people
who's like get over it olivia rodrigo
i don't think that this album is for you
but beyond that
she's just proven herself to be like an
incredibly talented musician songwriter
and artist
and i think that this is going to be
like a huge album for her and i cannot
wait like for her success because i'm a
really big fan
i agree there's also a lot of pressure i
imagine like to go from driver's license
like the album has to
in order for it to be as successful as
driver's license it literally would need
to break every record i hope that she's
like just
focusing on the art not letting the
pressure get to her but i imagine like
you know once you break every single
barrier it's like your follow-up well
you can only go down
right so but i think given the talent
that we know she has i think this album
will be really great
but i imagine she's feeling a lot of
pressure agreed but i do think the album
will be really successful for a
multitude of reasons one her follow-up
single
to driver's license like did not flop it
did very very well especially for like a
first-time artist like we forget like
this is her first
original piece of music like ever
released on her own
so deja vu did really really well and
she has the power of tick tock behind
her
driver's license blew up on tick tock
deja vu was like a trend on tick tock
like with the inverted filter
also i got rid of my tick tock time let
me yesterday like i was just so [ __ ]
fed up with being feeling guilty
so she has that on her side which as
anyone in the music industry knows like
if tick tocks on your side like
you are automatically like landing on
top 10 billboards so yeah she has that
and she has raw undeniable talent so
i don't think in any way could this
album be bad i agree i think there's
just like a lot of pressure to not be a
one-hit wonder because
the sk the success of driver's license
like
could be just that i don't think that it
is personally
but i'm sure that's like what everybody
is worried about yes but she
already is not a one-hit wonder to you
because you hear her song deja vu on
tick tock all the time but
for the people who for the people who
like just have heard
of driver's license outside of tic toc
like it's an snl sketch it's like
all these people who would never hear a
song by a 17 year old artist like it has
broken through every barrier deja vu
didn't
do that no but i totally disagree like
deja vu was number seven on billboard
like that
for like a first-time artist like that's
huge like you can't even though
tick-tock yes exists in its own space
there are real music industry
ramifications yes and i'm just saying i
don't get into an uber every day and
hear deja vu playing i literally hear a
driver's license all the time you can't
escape it and so i'm not saying deja vu
is not a successful song but like
it's not driver's license and that's
what like a one hit wonder sometimes can
be
is no i totally disagree what
like a one-hit wonder is a one-hit
wonder like deja vu
is it you're not a one-hit wonder if
your second song lands on the top 10 of
billboard
even if it's because of tick-tock the
the canon of
memory is so much longer than than just
like her next song
being number seven like if in a few
years from now
say nothing else were to happen like
driver's license is a one-hit wonder
regardless of deja vu hitting number
seven
no like billy ray cyrus is a one-hit
wonder with inky breaky heart i'm sure
he had other hits
i don't i'm sure he had other songs that
that were decent but like well that's
the reason because
harley ray jepson yeah call me maybe
yeah
and so i think that like she may be
struck again with the
siesta key song like 10 years later but
most people would regard her as siesta
key do you i mean as
call me maybe do you think she's a
one-hit wonder yes
okay so like if you think she's a
one-hit wonder and she actually has so
many
hits yeah but she but it's just because
of the the level that call me maybe
reach like really no other song can
can reach that but she didn't have other
songs immediately thereafter that even
charted
i think she literally fell off the face
of the earth no her whole all of her
albums have been so good like i love all
like
she has so many hits according to you no
i mean according to your standard of
hate but like olivia rodrigo
can't be considered a one-hit wonder
just because like not only did she break
all those barriers but she's also like
the darling of young hollywood like
she in the music industry like she is
adored like she's so
famous i know but it's it's like it
hasn't been that long i'm just saying i
don't know we'll see where the album
goes of course
yeah but i do think like she thanks to
deja vu is beyond the stigma of one hit
wonders
okay and i just want to say if you're
holding carly ray jepson if you're
saying that she's a one-hit wonder then
so far olivia
rodrigo can't have beat by the way you
can't have alcohol i don't think
i would say she's a one-hit wonder i
think the world would say but like i
respect and appreciate the art of
right i know a lot of people i know you
have respect and she's
huge in the gay community like she's a
gay
icon so because because the gay
community has taste
right no i know that you have respect
for carly and i know you saying how the
world remember
and i'm saying the world we're actually
saying the same thing i'm saying the
world has only her driver's license
even though deja vu is popular and
number one i disagree
okay but that's what it boils down to
the disagreement yes agreed i'm so glad
we got to the root of that issue
agreed but you know what only time will
tell so
you can agree with me you can agree with
claudia but only time hotel there's no
way to predict the future we'll see you
in time
i think we need a good five years before
we can call this one well we also have
to see like where the album
like lands like yeah how is it like are
there other songs that people love and
then like
once people start touring that's the
real tale of like whether or not you can
have music
do very well and chart and if you're
selling out
huge stadiums arena is like good for you
the real i feel like the real mark of
like what makes like a
an artist versus like a superstar is
like when you tour
who buys tickets are you coming who's
opening for you like what's it like are
you a good live performer
she's never performed live before yeah
well it's like she on high school
musical
she's never performed live as olivia she
performed in the auditorium she
performed in the high school musical
yes okay we'll keep your breath talk to
us in five years and we'll find out who
was right
yeah are you ready for our next story
yeah i literally feel so good about it
no like i know i think we all feel
really good about it here's the thing
though i wouldn't bet against olivia
rodrigo i'm just saying
that that could still happen for her
which is why i
imagine she's under a lot of pressure
but i yes i think she'll out
punch the pressure i hope so i'm just
letting you know there's pressure
yeah of course are you ready for our
next story a little happy bed ben news
brittany carter right has given birth
to a son cruz michael couchy on april
12th
i always forget that jax's last name is
not taylor because it should be
cruz michael taylor where his first name
should be taylor oh that'd be cute that
would be
cute but it's cruz which is also really
cute yeah really really cute popular
name on bravo
stephanie holman's son is named cruz as
is cameron wescott
spelled differently though yes i think i
think we have a z and we have a
nf a cruise ship but the heart rights
he was born on april 12th at 1 51 p.m
and they have never been more in love
he's the most precious gift and i'm so
blessed to be his mommy
it was really sweet i'm so happy for
them i feel like britney's just like
wanted a baby her whole life and i do
think that like
part of jax's kind of journey in the
last couple years to bettering himself
like
this is really like the the cherry on
top of it like i'm really happy for them
they're a really nice couple
and their baby's super cute and cruz is
a great great name and i can't wait to
see the mommy content coming from
brittany cartwright
yes and now we're three out of four of
the vanderbumps
yes sheena still has to give birth and
lala already gave birth tossy already
gave birth
and brittany so it's really crazy how it
all happened like yeah and by the way
considering everyone else
has girls cruz is officially the number
one guy in this school
oh my god you're right
so that score has been settled again
five years later and i'm so happy for
jax because like you know that that's
important to him
and it's like he really got everything
he ever wanted you know he got the house
in valley village and he got a son who's
the number one guy in this group
a hundred percent oh my god i love a
full circle moment
yeah happy for him happy for him happy
for cruz
know that i am are you ready for our
next story
yeah justin bieber says that the first
year of his marriage to haley baldwin
was really tough
oh my god like the jelena stands like
the people who still ship justin and
selena
like take every bit of news and like
blow it the [ __ ] up and it's
are they like thinking this may be
something yeah okay while gracing the
cover of gq's may issue the 27 year old
singer we counted low points in his life
that were caused by his own personal
struggles
and how his wife of two and a half years
hayley baldwin helped him out of those
dark moments
describing himself to the outlet as
someone who has always uh
who was always compelled to get married
he said i just felt like that was my
calling just to get married and have
babies and do that whole thing
however bieber went on to share how his
own personal demons caused a strain in
his marriage to the love of his
life quote the first year of marriage
was really tough because there was a lot
going back to the trauma
there was just a lack of trust there was
all these things that you don't want to
admit to the person that you're with
because it's scary
you don't want to scare them off by
saying i'm scared yeah i mean everyone
takes this as like well what does it
mean with that selena like is he talking
about that he was
afraid to talk to haley about selena and
it's like it's so disrespectful like
haley bieber and justin bieber have like
proved themselves to be otp like they're
so in love i think they're such a good
couple i think
they set like a good example for people
who like especially justin like i
actually have a lot of respect for him
like i think he's done a really good job
of like
showing how hard it was to get so famous
so young like the demons that you can
deal with and coming out of it on the
other side
and like he found jesus and he found a
wife and like i think he actually
in his own weird way like became a
really good role model for young people
and i i really like [ __ ] hate when
people just like keep making it about
celine it's like let selena move on with
her life even though like
she keeps singing songs about him and
let justin like move on with his life
like i just know that jelena stands are
like coming for this episode i can't
believe
jelena's stands like exists are still
around no no
and when he's talking about like the
trauma that and he's not
talking about selena my mind didn't go
to selena gomez i think we all know he's
like really struggled with like
substance abuse like that's where my
mind goes
yes and i think it's so admirable yeah
and so for anyone to make it about
anything
other than like his actual demons like
it's so [ __ ] disrespectful no it's so
disrespectful and so
surface level and i just don't know how
honestly hillary clinton's surface
lyrics
yes i don't know how haley bieber deals
with it like of course every celebrity
like signs up for like a certain amount
of
comments and trolling but like she gets
it more than anyone and it's like they
just don't [ __ ] leave her alone like
these
teeny boppers who are obsessed with
selena gomez like it's so rude i know
but like she's just on top of the world
like i hope she's so sick
i hope she finds a way to just like look
around her and just be like i'm gonna
ignore these teeny boppers
because i'm literally like the princess
diana of america like she's
literally really she is so cool and so
famous and so everything of the sort and
like i actually think she's like the
coolest girl i've ever met
so i'm so happy for her and like in
these last couple years i feel like
she's blossomed into being like you know
a friend of kendall jenner to like
being arguably just as cool and famous
if not more than kendall jenner no 100
she was just like another one in that
like group of sophia
yeah but she has just left her mark
and made her mark and every fashion on
society on
culture no 100 every day it's something
new and fabulous from hailey bieber and
i think that she's inspiring a
generation of fabulosity
and for that we have no choice but to
stand
yeah i agree so i i have had this like
journey with justin bieber in the last
few years
and now i am at a point where i have
such immense respect for him and his
journey
and i just love that like i think him
and haley are like really indestructible
like obviously knock on wood but like i
feel like they are
like they're settled i totally agree and
even reading this was surprising because
i feel like the day they decided to like
get engaged like they knew
exactly what they were doing and that it
was all like systems go from there
so to hear that the first year was
really tough was surprising because i
feel like even when i look at them now
i'm just like oh they're perfect perfect
yeah but they're also
they go through their own things you
know together they keep it personal
they're not like airing all their dirty
laundry
100 and that's why like we just
literally live for them 100 percent
are you ready for our fifth and final
story a little random reality news
oh it's not that bernie madoff died no
it's not that you were just sharing that
i was just letting you know that bernie
madoff died in prison at the age of 82
from a terminal
illness in case anybody wanted to know
bye i just didn't have anything to say
really beyond that no me neither
bye good day sir good day
sir um no our fifth and final story is a
little reality show news that i just
that i sent you last night oh this is
okay pepsi is um
setting a new ridiculous reality tv show
um it's a dating competition on mtv
called match me if you can
and it features a bunch of x reality
stars who i'll share with you like being
matched up it is also hosted by lauren
speed hamilton from love is blind which
is a very redeeming
aspect that is the only positive thing i
have to say about this particular show i
will get into why i think it is
the definition of a loser on loser
reality competition but
i think lauren hamilton like being
tapped as the next chris harrison
is so fabulous i know but this is also
so this is um
like a branded content viacom and pepsi
show like i think it might even be like
not a full shot i think it's going to be
like i
i had seen it was going to be after in
the finale of like another show
so it might just be like five minutes at
a time even though the trailer looked
like they went to
london yeah it looks like bachelor style
but
matchmaking if you can is produced by
viacom cbs is in-house branded content
studio the five-part series will bring
together
eight former reality tv stars including
ashley burke mitchell
i'm sorry to this woman what is she from
i don't know i don't know her
eric bigger we know from bachelor
natalie nagrati no no kyrah green
from love island i think she's gonna be
great and based on the previews she um
i'm sorry keira green
she might be linking up with harry josie
oh cute
yeah joey sasso he won the circle on
netflix
okay and kylie smith yeah no i'm so
sorry to this group of people i'm sure
they're all lovely but this is
really losery
especially because i don't even think
it's a real tv show it's a branded tv
show
which makes me think it's literally a
commercial yeah it's a commercial but
they like go on dates
and it's i it sounded like a good
concept for a reality tv show and like
half the cast at least the members said
i know like i feel good about eric
bigger
own yucca carriage yeah no i'm just
hosted by lauren hamilton like i feel
like there's something here
it also sort of reminds me of x on the
beach a little bit
yeah because at some point when you're
like a recycled reality star you're
really not going on reality tv to find
love you're going on it for career for
money for instagram followers
so do you think this is going to be like
a true love moment no
um no you never know
it's just this seemed a little illusory
to me sorry yeah no i knew
it seemed losery to you but i i happened
to watch like a lot of these shows yeah
like because i watched love island i
watched are you the one right
um so i'm kept depressed i watched you
have to handle i watch love is blind
i can't wait for both of those shows to
come back yeah that'll be really good
vanessa lashay
um put on her instagram story like she
had a day off while shooting too out to
handle in chicago
so like love is blind so it's coming and
the new season of too hot to handle has
been filmed oh
remember because that's part of the
drama between francesca
yes yes okay so
that was the fast five feels so you
needed to know some of them
um let's dive in which one um i'm
kidding i'm kidding
uh let's dive into tv recap did you
watch a real housewives of dallas last
night of course i did
actually it's not of course because yeah
you know it was cute like the redneck
relay was
cute it was cute you know what like the
episode was meh but i had a lot of
laughs
yes me too when cameron wescott
accidentally
dove into like that pile of [ __ ] because
she thought that's how you won the relay
like
i actually lost my mind no lost my mind
when stephanie and brandy dressed up as
bigfoot and then brandy started breaking
it down
as bigfoot like grinding i was laughing
so hard when brandy came in the next
morning and starts cleaning everything
up
as bigfoot like in the hot tub when
deandra was explaining why they were
like the billy bob thornton team and she
was like
because you need to be two names in
order to be in the south she was like
billy bob
bobby sue billy jim jim bob it was so
funny the episode was full with laughs
but it also was filled with a little bit
of drama that i actually
some of it i thought were really
interesting fights like when [ __ ] cat
uh
carrie dumped tomato juice all over
their beds
that was mean that's a friendship ending
move like
no good times are worth that 3 a.m and
you no longer have a bed to sleep in and
everything smells disgusting
also the house was in such disarray
all weekend i was just like how are
these fine ladies
of dallas like living like this [ __ ]
yeah
because it was such a nice house and the
second they got there the kitchen was a
mess the backyard was a
mess they were all like covered in
shaving cream and going in the hot tub
like
they did not get their deposit back
disgusting i can't imagine how it
smelled up in there
i know like they're so refined
especially like cameron
and tiffany like i just i was shocked
i was really it was literally like men
were in there yeah it was disgusting
it was disgusting they brought back the
um bigfoot hunter and carrie gave him
like one of the worst apologies i've
ever seen in my life and then he ended
up apologizing to her like
i just love this man and i really have
so much respect for stephanie for not
like just letting it go
and like bringing him back and making
him like remember this time with those
women fondly as opposed to like
oh that time i went on tv because i
thought it would be like fun and i ended
up getting embarrassed
100 and he refereed the redneck relay
and so i was glad that like
now he'll be remembered as the referee
hopefully um but still like i have a
weird feeling about the whole thing like
i still don't feel like great about it
and i just hope that if you're ever like
in oklahoma and you're looking to do a
bigfoot tour
that you call him yeah i just love to
like an icky feeling in my stomach i
just really am so overcarried like
she last week she had a little bit of
redemption when she was like visibly
remorseful about the whole little peepee
thing and just like acting like an
animal in the house
and here's the thing when you do
something like that you're so that you
feel that way about because you were
drunk and like you just have
this moral hangover and you're crying to
your friend here's what
here's what you don't drink that night
yeah you know because then she made a
bigger ass of herself with the tomato
juice
so i'm just like over her and it's like
i don't know
i'm just over her i'm so so over her
like
on the show i'm over her i'm over women
like being friends like i don't know how
you could be friends with someone that
think that that does that and thinks
that thinks that that that is a logical
response to a fart bomb
the group just like lets her get away
with so much and it's frustrating
and it's also frustrating that we now
know that she landed in new york for the
reunion and tested positive for covet so
she won't even really be
should be remote but she won't even be
there like really answer for her sins
you know
yeah that's frustrating because she's
probably the one who i feel like so far
she has the most answers and she's the
villain of the season
so that's really annoying and it's also
kind of weird that like the all the
women of dallas travel to new york when
like andy could easily just like go to
dallas for the day that's so tricky it
also
probably like increases the amount of
like risk for kovid
if there's 10 people traveling them in
their hair and makeup
versus just andy yeah but maybe between
all the crew and
production that they have in new york it
actually is less people if you fly the
women there
yeah it's just bizarre um so other than
that
it was a fun trip and there was like
funny moments but it's really not like
turning out to be much
no and there were so many moments in the
episode of like people's personal drama
that i was um
oh my god literally on my phone the
whole time okay so if something happened
i didn't i don't want to be rude but
like i really can't take the tiffany
stuff anymore like
and i'm sure everyone you said it last
week and you're right like everyone
films their personal stuff and they
definitely don't show everyone's but
like
it's the same conversation with her
husband and then the same one with her
mom and it seems like maybe last night
they put it to bed i
really hope so because i can't watch
anybody it's like in all the years of
your life if your mom like wasn't
someone who opened up to you and like
was super emotional like why do you
think now with a
film crew in your house is the best time
to do it it's so
boring and it's so lame and even deandra
who i
love i don't care like if you're gonna
make us watch stuff about like your step
family like getting back with them like
i want figures like how much money did
you take from the will and how much did
they take like
if we're gonna be forced to sit through
this family drama i want details i was
only watching with
one eye and one ear so i might have
missed half
but it sounded like she got it all but
again i'm on figures
i want figures yeah yeah also but it's
funny because
cameron's personal stuff with the spirit
is the job i was [ __ ] crying
but i also thought it was like so
beautiful like i i truly loved it
and i thought her scenes with court when
like he was talking about how like life
is really hard and serious and like he
loves living in a pink bubble with cam
like
crying no they are really cute i
personally did not love the dog
communicator segment oh my god
i loved it no i did not um but i agree i
think that like they're
they actually have like a really strong
marriage and i think a lot of people
could
like take some of the things court says
like out of context like
because sometimes it does feel like he
like thinks she's like silly or whatever
but i actually think he like so loves
that about her and i think it like makes
their life so fun
and i do think that cameron is actually
a lot smarter than she lets on and she's
probably like a boss [ __ ]
yeah i love her i love her so much and i
so much so that i even love the dog
communicator yeah
like i feel sad about the real
housewives of dallas because i feel like
there's a lot of gems mostly like
stephanie
and cameron who would do so well if it
was like an actual good show
but it's just not but it's like why
can't what's wrong
what i don't know fixing i don't know
there's like really not that many like
fights
i can't explain it like i know but then
it's like
okay so should leanne be there because
you said then it would pop off
fine like but like we were like it was
also infuriating when it's like
everyone's getting along and then
there's someone who's just like
stirring up like artificial drama and
it's like
you don't fit with the group you know i
just think that this is a group of women
who's like actually like
the definition of like southern belles
and like they really don't have that
much to fight about okay
no i agree but then it's like how come
beverly hills
well again like a group of women who
because they're in hollywood and there's
they're just like there's so much to
laces salaciousness and drama
like just naturally from being in l.a
like yeah it's a dramatic town i just
don't think that new york is
i mean dallas is a dramatic town i get
that and i also feel like because
they're in hollywood like they know that
they can play it up and that doesn't
have any like real bearing on their
personal lives right like in dallas i
think that they are
all very protective yes of their image
and their family
so like i don't think they're holding
back i just don't think that
me either it's just boring yeah so
that's that on that um
is it okay if i dive into your toaster
it is okay i feel ready i look forward
to seeing what you guys have for us this
week hopefully an update
hopefully do we have an update oh we do
we do okay so let's dive in uh dear
toasters is our advice
segment we do it weekly on wednesdays so
if you ever want to write in get our
advice you can do it anonymously you can
change people's names the email is dear
toasters
gmail.com and if you've written in
recently and you have an update for us
please update us hi jackie and claudia i
have a very weird story stick with me
i live in a very nice quiet and well
taken care of condo complex in central
florida
full of mostly retirees and working
professionals like myself
the building is mostly open to the
outside no doorman or anything like that
i've been living in the same condo for
five years and about three years ago my
across the hall neighbors moved out
since the day of the move out there has
been no one officially living across the
hall
however about the time that they left i
noticed that there was an extra large
water bottle outside the door
i immediately thought that this water
bottle was just left there by someone
moving
moving out or working in the condo but i
swear the same water bottle randomly
appears outside the door to this day
sometimes it's in the same exact spot
and sometimes it's a little bit of a
different spot but it is always the same
water bottle and is always full of a
clear substance
that i assume is water it looks like a
half used normal everyday water bottle
and for the longest time i just assumed
someone meant to put it in the trash but
forgot
but now that it has been this long and
it's still there i just don't get it
why is it still there literally three
years later why is it gone outside
why is it gone some days and back the
next is it a signaling device is someone
filling it and leaving it outside for
someone
there's still no one living across the
hall but someone does come in and come
in
and out every once in a while i've
noticed the doormat is sometimes a skew
a skew
or the lights are on i know the condo
was sold to someone slash some company
about a year ago but the water bottle is
still
there should i confront the person who
comes in and out of the unit should i
call the police
should i just pick up the damn water
bottle and throw it in the trash is this
a front for an international crime
organization that uses it to signal
people
have i been watching one too many
episodes of law order blue bloods what
do i do all assistance is greatly
appreciated
um i don't think it's a front for an
international crime organization but i
do think you should get a ring doorbell
and just surveil the situation
because if anything this is just like a
fun activity for you until you find out
that like it is crime
for now it's just like a fun little
maybe you are listening to like one too
many true crime podcasts
but there is something weird about it so
like get a ring get like a cheap
ring from like amazon yeah or like a
furbo nest whatever
and just survey the premises yeah i
think it's a good thing to have
regardless you know to invest in your
security so especially if there's
something
going on there's definitely something
like weird but i don't know if i would
jump to crime yet
but we are living in crazy times my
initial thought was squatter
me too my initial thought was squatter
immediately and like maybe someone knows
that the squatter's there
leaving them water this this is squatter
central but
yeah the apartment was uh sold
but not used permanently so that's the
perfect place for a squatter 100
someone is living it up in the central
florida condo
sounds nice yeah like me it's a squatter
situation
but get a ring doorbell because i want
to know what it is yeah me too and
update us
alright next up hey claudia jackie how
you doing daring it this is a long one
here we go back in november of 2019 one
of my who i thought was my best friends
got engaged to the man of her dreams and
i was asked to be a bridesmaid when
coven 19 lasted longer than the expected
two weeks
plans changed and the maid of honor told
everyone that the bachelorette was
postponed indefinitely
i took kovid super seriously because
both my parents are high risk
i'm still open for meeting up and
walking outside the bride and i met up a
few times and whenever the wedding came
up she told me she wasn't sure what she
was going to do
i didn't want to be annoying but i kept
reminding her that i was there for her
for whatever she needed
one day i see a bunch of instagram
stories of a bachelorette party that's
going on
instantly i got a pit the bride posted a
picture and said something
along the lines of thanks to my girls
for surprising me with a wine tasting
day trip for my bachelorette party
i decided to call her and leave her a
message saying i missed her and that
i saw she had a bachelorette party and
was sad to not be included but that i
still wish for the best and asked to
meet up that week
she texted me back and said that it was
a surprise and that since i had been
taking covert so seriously
the maid of honor figured i wouldn't go
since they did not reach out
however i'm a teacher i've been double
vaccinated for a while and my parents
have been too
i would have loved an invitation
eventually we met up for coffee and she
told me her and her fiance were planning
to elope in vegas in a couple of weeks
i told her i was so happy for her but
something still didn't feel right two
weeks later i see that she got married
in vegas with the rest of the bridal
party and 50 people
i felt blindsided and lied to seeing as
how she told me she was eloping
did she not think i would see the social
media posts i unfollowed everyone
because i was honestly so sad and it was
crushing me to see this
i also unfollowed the bride on find my
friends because i didn't want to be
obsessing over checking it
i got a text from the bride about me and
following her and find my friends and on
instagram the text was long
but said she had to give up a lot of
things to be married during cobid
and that she loved and respected me she
said that she wished i could have been
there i
did not reply because i don't understand
how i go from being in the wedding to
not being included in a small
destination wedding where all the other
bridal party members and their husbands
and boyfriends
were invited to fast forward to today
and i still have not replied to the text
because i don't even know where to begin
should i reach out any help would be so
appreciated appreciated
sincerely a cancelled bridesmaid but a
proud toaster
this is like making me sad like the
longer we went on it's like girl like
literally cut you out of the wedding
like there's no excuse for any of that
and i don't even really feel like you
have to respond to her text message like
she's made it abundantly clear like she
literally wants nothing to know like
she's literally gonna like
gaslight you and tell you like you've
done nothing wrong and then continue to
hurt your feelings and like
i'm really confused but i also
i like
i don't know how to say this but i feel
like she when people show you your true
colors
you have to look at them no i know but
like literally made it very clear like
she doesn't want to be your friend
why do you but like you guys have been
friends for a while you said like you
were going to be a
bridesmaid like why doesn't you want to
be your friend anymore like if i were
you i would just want to know like
what happened yeah um because it sounds
like
maybe you did something i don't know it
sounds like you guys are like beating
around the bush like okay if you're
gonna respond to the text message and be
like
you've made it abundantly clear like you
don't want to be my friend and you don't
want me at your wedding and like can you
let me know if there's anything that i
did just so i can know for my future
friendships just like
be like message received i've got the
message yeah i'm i'm not upset about
abundantly clean
i'm not and i would do this like even
maybe in person so she can't like
screw around the issue and like send a
fake ass text message like i would just
go to coffee again be like i've have
received your message like
you don't my receiver is on i'm not
important to you and you know what
sometimes friendships
they fade and and not every friendship
is meant to last forever and it's been a
crazy year and things change and i
understand that
i just don't like need to know what i
did or what because it's
beating me up like i can't sleep yeah no
like because it's like an
unsolved mystery of my life like please
if you ever cared about me as a friend
just like
let me know and just make sure to like
get over the fact that like she
like virtually dumped you like get over
it yeah work it out internally before
you go meet with her so you don't like
start crying like
then be like i have come to peace with
the i've made peace with the fact that
like
you want nothing to do with me i have
received your message my receiver is on
can you just let me know like what the
reasoning was like did you just like get
over me did i offend you like
are you jealous like what was what was
the reason like because i'm just going
off of the information that you gave us
again the only thing that i could
conceive of if unless you left something
out it's like maybe because you were
mia all of 2020 because you were high
risk for kovid
that maybe everyone was hanging out all
the time this year like every single day
they became
best friends and like there was no way
to bring you back in but like
far-fetched far-fetched but that's a
really good plan like
come to terms with it make peace with it
and then go talk to her and just be very
matter-of-fact about it
finding mission because i want to know
as well yeah
i want to know all right our final one
is an update hello claudia jackie
bruno and theo oh bruce i miss him i
didn't think that my story was that
interesting so i was unsure if i should
send an update but i decided why not if
you don't remember i was a toaster that
thought she might have seen a dating app
on her dad's phone
well you both told me not to snoop and
not to tell my mom and guess who didn't
listen
i just morally couldn't keep that to
myself it felt wrong plus i'm nosy as
hell
a couple days after i emailed you i saw
my dad left his phone unlocked and he
walked away
being the nosy person that i am i took a
look and found that he did have tinder
downloaded
i ended up telling my mom and they split
but after a couple months of being a
part my parents decided they wanted to
try starting
they didn't want to try starting over at
their this age so they got back together
i regret not listening to you ladies
because i just found this whole thing
strange and i wish i wasn't a part of it
anymore
plus i now seem like the crazy one
because i find it hard to trust my dad
while everyone thinks everything is fine
whatever i guess give the pups a hug for
me love a toaster should have [ __ ]
listened
i'm so sorry but you know what it
actually sounds like maybe you did the
right thing like
you got it because now she's like no no
she's business she's a family snitch
and they ended up exactly where they
started no i know but like at least like
you're not
burdening yourself with this secret and
you have to strengthen trust with your
mom
and like there's there was honesty and
really honesty is the best policy so
don't
beat yourself up about it like sure
you're the family stitch
no i think maybe you should beat
yourself up about it just a little bit
because we told you exactly what to do
when you didn't listen and
now it's like she's right like there is
like a brokenness between her and her
dad because like
she was already if she even if she
didn't say anything to anyone she would
not trust that man again and she would
always like
feel some type of way about stuff so
first so like you got everything out
there
and they ended up back together if they
didn't end up back together and was like
they were both like
living like in a condo and like feeling
really sad and like their lives were
just like completely
upended i would be like yeah you should
have listened to us yeah i guess
but because like it all everything
happened and they're back together like
i actually feel like
it's okay okay give yourself some grace
thank you for the update we really
appreciate it and again i can't stress
enough if you have written in to us and
we've given you
good bad or decent advice please email
us an update we want to know how things
worked out and here's the thing you
might be the family snitch but
someone's got to be so true that email
is dear toasters at gmail.com again if
you ever want to write in
the merch is now live head over to
shopmorningtoast.com
get your crew next get your mugs get
your sweaters get your hat um we love
you guys thank you so much for
supporting this launch
and we hope you have an amazing hump day
again cannot stress do not forget to
help someone you love
don't forget sometimes i feel like
people forget and it's so important but
that's why we do what we do
to remind them love you guys thank you
so much for listening to the morning
toast the millennial morning show where
we deliver the past five stories that
you need to know every monday through
friday on youtube so if you're listening
to us on youtube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up
we're so bellows the podcast anywhere
podcasts we found so it's spotify
institute public radio i already catch
box
all the places surrounding us in a
podcast find us some more details leave
a five-star review about how beautiful
stunning and smart we are
hope you have an amazing hump day we
will see you guys tomorrow for
thursday we are so close so exciting
we'll see you goodbye